I couldn't figure it out. I was hitting on a lot of straight people. This is Anna Pulley. She's a writer. And when she moved from Chicago to San Francisco, she didn't know who to hit on anymore. Midwestern queer culture is extremely different than Bay Area queer culture. And one of the things that was most noticeable to me was fashion. Some of the queer signals from the Midwest didn't quite hold, like, plaid flannel shirts. I wear flannel and I feel, gare. In the Midwest, way more so, I think.
我当时根本搞不懂。我搭讪过很多直人。这是安娜·普利（Anna Pulley）。她是一位作家。当她从芝加哥搬到旧金山时，她不知道该去搭讪谁了。中西部的酷儿文化与湾区酷儿文化截然不同。对我来说，最显眼的特征之一就是时尚。中西部的一些酷儿标志不太管用了，比如格子法兰绒衬衫。我穿法兰绒衣服时会觉得自己很酷。在中西部，这种感觉要强烈得多，我觉得。
If you are part of a group, there are things you can wear or ways you can style your hair, signs that show that you are part of that group. Flannel was one way to signify, like, I exist. But you can't really stop other people from wearing these signals. And so eventually the power of that signal gets diluted. So if you see someone wearing plaid, no, doesn't mean anything to you?
如果你属于某个群体，你会有一些可以穿的衣服、可以弄的发型，或者能表明你是该群体一员的标志。法兰绒曾是一种宣示“我存在”的方式。但你其实无法阻止其他人也穿戴这些标志。因此，最终这种标志的力量就被稀释了。所以如果你看到有人穿格子衣服，不，这对你来说毫无意义？
Well, I might first think, are you a bicamessenger? Oh, I'm a bicamessenger. And then the next thing you know, you can't even tell what clothing is signaling what anymore. Yeah, one night I was rebuffed by this straight lady and I got upset about it. And also I'd been thinking about hipsters a lot because they appropriate a lot of working-class culture motifs. And flannel is one of them. So it doesn't seem like lesbians are appropriating, working classware? Yeah, so that's an interesting, I don't know who actually owns, you know,
嗯，我首先可能会想：你是自行车信使吗？哦，我是自行车信使。然后紧接着，你甚至分不清什么衣服代表什么标志了。是的，有一天我被一位直女冷落了，我为此感到沮丧。而且我也一直在思考嬉皮士，因为他们挪用了大量工人阶级的文化元素。而法兰绒就是其中之一。所以这看起来不就像女同性恋在挪用工人阶级的服饰吗？是的，这是一个有趣的问题，我不知道究竟谁拥有，你知道的，
if anyone can own a fabric. Articles of interest, a show about what we wear. And so maybe the ideas about clothes you can attach or ideas about class an idea of home to a piece of cloth Any fork and wear clothes, but if you ain't got the attitude and style to carry it off man, you're just a closed horse Lumberjack's war plaid punk punks war plaid mini skirts, the beach boys. I kid you not. Used to be called the Pendletones and they were plaid with their surfboards.
如果有人能拥有某种面料的话。《感兴趣的物件》，一档关于我们穿着的节目。因此，也许人们会把关于服装的想法，或者关于阶级、关于家的概念，附加到一块布料上。任何人都可以穿衣服，但如果你没有那种驾驭它的态度和风格，老兄，你只是个衣架子。伐木工穿格子呢，朋克也穿格子呢，迷你裙，还有海滩男孩。我没开玩笑。他们以前叫彭德尔顿乐队（Pendeltones），他们带着冲浪板穿着格子衬衫。
So many different groups have adopted plaid. So it almost doesn't mean anything anymore. And really, why are we all wearing this? This particular pattern, which once once upon a time, was mostly concentrated in the upper corner of this one island off the coast of Europe. Certainly for Scotland, its dress. Dress is the thing that identifies people in Scotland, it dress people's their bagpipes as well.
如此多的不同群体都采用了格子呢。以至于它现在几乎失去了任何意义。说真的，为什么我们所有人都在穿这个？这个特定的图案，曾几何时，主要集中在欧洲海岸外这单个岛屿的北部角落。对苏格兰而言，这绝对是他们的民族服饰。服饰是苏格兰人身份的标识，服饰也是他们的风笛。
This is Peter McDonald, the historian at the Scottish Tartons Authority. They call this pattern tartan, not plaid. We don't use that word for patterns in this country. Platt is a government. The Scotsman who lived in the Highlands, the northern hilly part of the country, used to wrap themselves in a cloth. Almost like a blanket, kind of like an Indian sorry.
这是彼得·麦克唐纳（Peter McDonald），苏格兰格子呢管理局的历史学家。他们把这种图案称为“tartan”，而不是“plaid”。我们在国内不用后一个词来指代图案。“plaid”是一种服饰。居住在苏格兰高地（即该国北部丘陵地带）的苏格兰人过去常常用一块布把自己裹起来。几乎就像一条毯子，有点像印度的纱丽。
So if you like it's a tartan saree, would be the nearest equivalent? That bolt of cloth was called a plaid, and it had a tartan pattern on it. That's how the term got into the US, and that where they become synonymous with the pattern. It's not like back then there were tartan shirts and tartan scarves. No, tartan was on these traditional plads and overcoats and on the traditional pants,
所以如果你愿意的话，它就像一条格子呢纱丽，这会是最接近的等价物？那卷布被称为“plaid”，上面有“tartan”的图案。这个词就是这样进入美国的，并在那里与这种图案成了同义词。并不是说当时有什么格子衬衫和格子围巾。不，tartan图案只存在于这些传统的格子呢大衣、外套以及传统裤子上，
which were called trues. Trues are tartan trowels, but they're not trowsies because they're tights, they included the feet, so they're more like ladies' tights, you know. So tartan was kind of this parochial little pattern, but Scotsmen in the country used to wear, and it was pretty much only used on these obscure traditional Highland garments that I had never heard of before. And then something happened. Something that would end up turning Tarton loose on the world. These obscure traditional Highland clothes were banned.
这些裤子被称为“trues”。Trues是格子呢紧身裤，但它们不是普通的裤子，因为它们是紧身裤，还连着脚，所以它们更像是女士连裤袜，你知道的。因此，tartan曾是一种带有浓郁地方色彩的小众图案，过去只有乡村的苏格兰人会穿，而且它几乎只用在我以前从未听说过的不起眼的传统高地服饰上。然后，事情发生了。一件最终将tartan向全世界解禁的事情发生了。这些不起眼的传统高地服饰被禁了。
The Act banned, it killed, plaidids and other elements of Highland dress and outdoor coats in Tartan you can't wear as well. The Act Peter McDonald is talking about is the Dress Act of 1746. Scotland was being taken over by the Hannavarian Empire. And many of the Scots who fought back were from the Highlands and so they wore tartan coats and Keltz and plaids. Put in modern pilots, they would be seen as terrorists, or freedom fighters depending on which side you were on, but that's the reason for the ban.
该法案禁止、扼杀了格子呢衣物、其他高地服饰元素以及tartan面料的外套，你也不准穿。彼得·麦克唐纳所说的法案是1746年的《服饰法案》。苏格兰当时正被汉诺威王朝接管。许多进行反抗的苏格兰人都来自高地，因此他们穿着tartan外套、短裙和格子呢。用现代的话来说，根据你站在哪一边，他们会被视为恐怖分子或自由战士，但这就是颁布禁令的原因。
It was a way to suppress the resistance by limiting what they wore. Men were not allowed to wear highland clothes for 35 years in Scotland. But here's the thing. Just like banned books become the cool thing to read. When Scottish clothes were banned, they became the cool thing to wear. As always, when you're not allowed to wear something, that means somebody else immediately will.
这是通过限制人们的着装来镇压抵抗的一种方式。在苏格兰，男性曾有35年不被允许穿着高地服装。但关键是。就像禁书会成为最酷的阅读选择一样。当苏格兰服饰被禁时，它们反而成了最酷的穿着。一如既往，当你不被允许穿某种衣服时，这就意味着其他人马上就会去穿。
This is Jonathan Faire's author of the book, Tarton. And he says what the ban did was that it made Highland clothes trendy outside of Scotland. Suddenly, Tartan was also being worn in England. That moment made Tartan a fashionable fabric. It was no longer a sign of indigenous Highlanders. It became something that perhaps lowlanders or English people with scotish sympathy started to wear. But Scottish men had an option.
这是《格子呢》一书的作者乔纳森·费尔（Jonathan Faires）。他说，这项禁令所做的事，是让高地服饰在苏格兰以外的地方变得时髦起来。突然之间，英格兰人也开始穿tartan格子呢了。那一刻使tartan成为了一种时尚的面料。它不再是本土高地人的标志。它变成了一种或许是低地人或对苏格兰有好感的英格兰人开始穿的东西。但苏格兰男人们有别的选择。
If they wanted to keep wearing their traditional clothes during the ban, there was a loophole. They could go fight for the British Empire. The ban didn't apply to Scotsmen who joined the army. So over time, it encouraged people if they wanted to continue into a native garb to join the military. This meant Scotsman wearing tartans were deployed around the world, which influenced the style and popularity of similar-looking patterns across the colonies, like Madras and India.
如果他们在禁令期间还想继续穿他们的传统服装，有一个漏洞。他们可以去为大英帝国效力。禁令不适用于加入军队的苏格兰人。因此随着时间的推移，这鼓励了那些想要继续穿着民族服饰的人去参军。这意味着身穿tartan格子呢的苏格兰士兵被部署到世界各地，这影响了殖民地中类似外观图案的风格和流行，比如印度的马德拉斯格子（Madras）。
Although I would say Madras. And checkered bandanas and Jamaica, and the chukka cloth of the Messiah warriors. The colonialism of the British Empire spread these influences around and increased global demand for tartan and tartan-like fabrics. The presence of highland, regimental soldiers wearing tartan and some form or another would have influenced people directly
虽然我会说马德拉斯。还有牙买加的方格头巾，以及马赛勇士的楚卡布（chukka cloth）。大英帝国的主义将这些影响传播到各处，并增加了全球对tartan以及类似tartan面料的需求。身穿各种形式tartan服饰的高地军团士兵的存在，会直接对人们产生影响，
on a purely aesthetic way. And meanwhile, people in England with Scottish sympathies all got together in 1778 and made a kind of booster group to advocate for Scottish culture. Something called the Highland Society of London was formed in order to try and preserve the customs and manners, what was called the Highland Revival, the Great Highland Revival. They were responsible for the repeal of the dress act in 1782. And so by the time the dress band was finally lifted,
纯粹是从审美的角度。与此同时，对苏格兰抱有同情的英格兰人在1778年聚在一起，成立了一个旨在倡导苏格兰文化的助威组织。为了试图保护风俗习惯，成立了一个名为“伦敦苏格兰人协会”（Highland Society of London）的组织，这就是所谓的“高地复兴运动”（Highland Revival），伟大的高地复兴运动。他们负责在1782年废除了《服饰法案》。因此，当服饰禁令最终解除时，
it was just like Tartan Mania. The great Highland revival was in full swing. Scottish soldiers were coming home, and now they could wear their Tartan, and Englishmen were wearing Tartan, and people all over the colonies were wearing Tartan, and North Americans were really wearing Tartan. Obviously, the kind of work shirt
这简直就像是一场狂热的“格子呢狂热”（Tartan Mania）。伟大的高地复兴运动正如火如荼地进行。苏格兰士兵正在回家，现在他们可以穿他们的tartan格子呢了，英格兰人在穿tartan，殖民地各处的人们都在穿tartan，而北美洲的人们更是实实在在地在穿tartan。显然，那种你特别认同为美国风格的工作衬衫，
that you would particularly identify with American, I'd just say a kind of plaid working shirt. If you go back some of the earliest cloths that we used for to make those work shirts, were exported from Scotland. Tartan became a massive export to the United States. Tartan was a huge export to America in the 1700s, early 1800s. In the United States, Tart was a huge export to America in the 1700s, early 1800s.
我会说那就是一种格子工作衬衫。如果你追溯那些用来制作这些工作衬衫的最早面料，它们是从苏格兰出口的。Tartan格子呢成为了向美国出口的大宗商品。在18世纪和19世纪初，Tartan是向美国出口的大宗商品。在美国，Tartan在18世纪和19世纪初也是向美国出口的大宗商品。
In the United States, Tartin was also a symbol of heritage and belonging, if you were a Scotsman who was made to flee your homeland. Or if you literally belonged to a Scotsman. There were lots of very powerful Scottish families very active in the slave trade. These kinds of records are hard to find, but it's said that enslaved people across the colonies also wore tartan-patterned cloth. Because tartan is bright and noticeable. Slaves would be made to wear a cloth with a particular tartan, which said who they belonged to. You were being marked, you were being branded by your owners, by your oppressors, which is pretty chilling, but it certainly for those people was very much a cloth of oppression.
在美国，如果你是一个被迫逃离祖国的苏格兰人，Tartan也是传统和归属感的象征。或者如果你字面上属于某个苏格兰人。有许多非常有权势的苏格兰家族积极参与奴隶贸易。这类记录很难找到，但据说殖民地各处的被奴隶者也穿着用tartan图案制作的布料。因为tartan颜色鲜艳、引人注目。奴隶们被迫穿上带有特定tartan图案的布料，这表明他们属于谁。你被作了记号，你被你的主人、你的压迫者烙上了印记，这相当令人不寒而栗，但对这些人来说，它绝对是彻头彻尾的压迫布料。
Tartan has been, in many ways, a cloth of oppression, whether the Scots were being oppressed themselves or acting as the hand of the British Empire or perpetuating the global slave trade. And it functions efficiently as a cloth of oppression because it is so loud and highly visible. I do think it has this idea of almost negating the body and becoming literally just the pattern, so you are literally kind of becoming the brand. And tartan can be a brand of so many different conflicting things. In the United States, tartan can be a nod to a many different conflicting things. In the United States, Tarton can be a nod to a rugged highlander, or a monarket colonizer, and that's a side from its associations with I think it is probably associated with ideas of colonialism and empire.
在许多方面，Tartan一直是一块压迫的布料，不论苏格兰人是被压迫者，还是充当大英帝国的手下，亦或是延续全球奴隶贸易。它作为压迫布料之所以能高效运作，是因为它如此高调且显眼。我确实认为它带有一种几乎是否定肉体、字面上完全变成图案的感觉，所以你字面上有点变成了这个品牌。而Tartan可以成为许多不同且相互冲突的事物的品牌。在美国，Tartan既可以是对粗犷高地人的致敬，也可以是对君主制殖民者的致敬，这还不算它与——我认为它可能与殖民主义和帝国的观念有关。
And that's a side from its associations with queerness or lumberjacks or cowboys or bike messengers. Quite literally, there's a tartan for everything. These are the tartan swatches. Dee Williams works at the National Records of Scotland. In these boxes here, and she is showing me the Scottish register of Tartans which is very much not open to the public. How often does someone come to actually at the point? You are the first? Well she said I was the first journalist who
这还不算它与酷儿群体、伐木工、牛仔或自行车信使的联系。毫不夸张地说，万物皆可有tartan。这些是格子呢色卡。迪·威廉姆斯（Dee Williams）在苏格兰国家档案馆工作。在这些盒子里，她向我展示了苏格兰格子呢登记册（Scottish Register of Tartans），这个登记册是绝不对公众开放的。人们多久会来看一次实物？你是第一个？嗯，她说我是第一个来这里的记者。
had been in there. Generally we don't we don't offer this. We don't say to people come in and look at all the swatches. Anybody can look online by the way. They can look up every tartan online. There's in that register. They just need to put in a search. They just need to put in a name and it will come back. Tartans traditionally have been associated with Scottish names.
通常我们不会这样做。我们不会对人们说，进来看看所有的色卡吧。顺便说一句，任何人都可以上网查看。他们可以在网上查到每一个格子呢。登记册里都有。他们只需要输入一个搜索词。他们只需要输入一个名字，就会显示结果。传统上，格子呢与苏格兰姓氏息息相关。
So if your last name is McClain or McAllen or Hany, you can look up the traditional Tartans associated with your clan. I had the clan chief Dr. David Hany came in today and he was looking up his Hany Tartans associated with your clam. I had the Client Chief, Dr. David Hane came in today, and he was looking up his Hane Tartans. But it's not like everyone who lives in Scotland has this long family history
所以如果你的姓氏是麦克莱恩（McClain）、麦卡伦（McAllen）或哈尼（Hany），你可以查到与你家族相关的传统格子呢。今天，族长大卫·哈尼（David Hany）博士来了，他在查找他的哈尼家族格子呢。今天，族长大卫·哈尼博士来了，他在查找他的哈尼家族格子呢。但并不是说每个住在苏格兰的人都有这样漫长的家族历史，
with a traditional last name and a family tartan. And in Scotland, people wear tartan kilts to weddings and funerals and parties. And so, what are you supposed to wear if you're not from a clam? That's where you get other people. They've got personal tartans. Personal tartans for them.
有着传统的姓氏和家族格子呢。在苏格兰，人们在婚礼、葬礼和派对上都会穿格子呢短裙。所以，如果你不是来自某个氏族，你该穿什么呢？这就是为什么会有其他人。他们拥有了个人格子呢。为他们自己专属的个人格子呢。
So they've designed a tartan. They really want it just for them. You've also got organization corporate ones. A lot of military ones being registered lately. No matter who you are, or how not Scottish you are, I will bet money that if you peruse the register of tartans, you will eventually find a tartan for something that you like
所以他们设计了一种格子呢。他们真的希望它是专属于自己的。你还可以拥有组织或企业专属的格子呢。最近注册了许多军队用的格子呢。不管你是谁，或者你有多么不具备苏格兰血统，我敢打赌，如果你仔细翻阅格子呢登记册，你最终会为你喜欢的东西或能与之产生共鸣的事物找到一款格子呢。
or can identify with. The zoo panda one. The panda at the Edinburgh zoo has a tartan. It's not like it has pandas on it, it's still just a tartan, but it's black and white. So these are some kinds of scoters. There's a San Francisco tartan. That one. The San Francisco tartan is sandy and scarlet, like the colors of the 49ers. New Jersey's tartan is a sand and blue and little slender bits of red.
大熊猫的那款。爱丁堡动物园的大熊猫就有一款格子呢。倒不是说上面印着熊猫，它依然只是格子呢，但它是黑白相间的。所以这些是某些种类的格子呢。这里有一款旧金山格子呢。就是那款。旧金山格子呢是沙色和猩红色的，就像49人队（49ers）的颜色一样。新泽西州的格子呢是沙色、蓝色以及一点点纤细的红色。
Most states in the US have an official tartan and a lot of countries have one. It's in Bobway, News in Bobway, Kenya. Oh wow, this is the Africa folder. Volkswagen, American Express and Coca-Cola have tartans, Nike has a couple. And there is a tartan for the Scottish register of tartans. There is a Scottish register of tartan tartan? Yes. You too could have your very own official tartan.
美国的大多数州都有官方格子呢，许多国家也有。津巴布韦，津巴布韦有，肯尼亚也有。哦哇，这是非洲文件夹。大众、美国运通和可口可乐都有各自的格子呢，耐克也有好几款。而且，苏格兰格子呢登记册本身也有一款格子呢。苏格兰格子呢登记册居然也有格子呢？对。你也可以拥有属于你自己的官方格子呢。
The certificate costs 70 pounds, and it's 100 pounds if you want it in a wooden frame. But you'll get the tartan name, you'll get the registration number. You can design your own tartan in literally 10 minutes. Because official tartans don't have to be cloth anymore. Online tartan. You can go to any number of online tartan generators. to be cloth anymore. Online, Tartan, and writer.
证书费用是70英镑，如果想要木质相框则是100英镑。但你会得到格子呢的名称，你会得到注册号。你字面上可以在10分钟内设计出你自己的格子呢。因为官方格子呢不再必须是真正的布料了。在线格子呢。你可以访问任何一家在线格子呢生成器。不再必须是布料了。在线格子呢生成器。
You can go to any number of online Tartan generators. They're a unique business, club, or personal plaid. And input the colors you want. Choose power. And the thread count, I can adjust the thickness. And ta-da, you have a Tartan, and now it's just saving my Tartan. You'll get Tartan people designing a Tartan
你可以访问任何数量的在线格子呢生成器。它们可以为你打造独特的企业、俱乐部或个人格子呢。然后输入你想要的颜色。选择克重。还有纱线支数，我可以调整厚度。然后塔哒，你就拥有了一款格子呢，现在它正在保存我的格子呢。你会发现有人为他们的狗设计格子呢，
for their dog, you know, or their dead relative and, you know, into thinking why? Our historian friend Peter McDonald is part of the committee that assesses the incoming tartans. They get around eight proposals a week. Quite a lot of what I would call vanity tartans, they're never going to be woven, they're never going to be worn and it's because they can, you know, which doesn't make them good or tasteful or meaningful, frankly. I mean, do some of these threatens get denied? Yes.
你知道的，或者为他们死去的亲人，然后，你就会纳闷：为什么？我们的历史学家朋友彼得·麦克唐纳是审核新提交格子呢的委员会成员之一。他们大约每周收到八份提案。其中有相当多我所谓的虚荣格子呢，它们永远不会被织出来，永远不会被穿在身上，而这只是因为他们“可以”（这么做），你知道的，坦白讲，这并没有让它们变得更好、更有品味或更有意义。我的意思是，其中一些格子呢会被拒绝吗？是的。
And of the new incoming tartans, the majority of them are not from Scotland. Well, top of my head, 70% come from North America, probably most from the US, but a size of proportion from Canada as well. Quite a few from Japan, a lot of Japanese schools seem to like tartans or uniforms, and they did sound from Scotland. But yeah, the majority of them come from America. America is really into tartan. I mean, just go to New York City on April 6th.
在所有新提交的格子呢中，大多数都不是来自苏格兰的。嗯，凭我的记忆，70%来自北美，可能大部分来自美国，但相当大一部分来自加拿大。还有相当一部分来自日本，许多日本学校似乎很喜欢格子呢校服，而来自苏格兰的反而听起来没那么多。不过是的，它们大多数来自美国。美国人对格子呢非常着迷。我是说，只要看看4月6日的纽约市就知道了。
That's National Tartan Day, and they put on this huge parade with bagpipes and Scottish terriers and Scottish associations from all over the US. Tartan is one way that white people can claim some sort of cultural heritage. Because you're a young country, you all want to claim your heritage and actually a lot of people claim either Scots or Irish ancestry because it has the cultural icons and identity which help you belong. And everyone wants to belong to something, somewhere, somehow. There was about a 30% increase last year of Tartan's registered. So it's definitely only increase.
那是全国格子呢日，他们会举办一场盛大的游行，有风笛、苏格兰梗犬以及来自全美各地的苏格兰人协会。格子呢是白人宣称某种文化遗产的一种方式。因为你们是一个年轻的国家，你们都想宣称自己的血统，事实上很多人都声称自己有苏格兰或爱尔兰血统，因为这拥有能帮你找到归属感的文化符号和身份认同。每个人都想对某样东西、某个地方、以某种方式产生归属感。去年注册的格子呢数量大约增加了30%。所以它绝对是在增长的。
In some ways, if you don't get your tartan actually woven, the register of tartans might seem like a cheesy thrill, like one of those online services where you can pay to register a star or buy a plot of land on the moon. But those authentic clan tartans, the ones that represent last names, those were also kind of made up. When you look actually at early examples of surviving tartans, it would not really have been associated with particular families, and
在某些方面，如果你没有真正把你的格子呢织成布，格子呢登记册可能看起来像是一种俗气的刺激，就像那些花钱在网上注册一颗星星或在月球上买一块地的在线服务一样。但那些正宗的氏族格子呢，那些代表姓氏的格子呢，其实也是某种程度上捏造出来的。如果你仔细看看现存早期格子呢的样本，它们其实根本不会与特定的家族相关联，并且
there is no way that 6200 people, Clansmen, could all be wearing the same tartan. This idea of official clan tartans was part of the Great Highland Revival. Gosh, clan tartans start around 1810. Okay, yes, 200 years is old, but that's nothing when you compare it to the ages of the clans themselves. The Macduff, the Macdougles, the Macquaries, the Macallons, those are closer to a thousand years old. But basically, in the 1800s, many of the clan leaders just went and picked out tartans they liked
绝不可能有6200人——也就是氏族成员——都穿着一模一样的格子呢。这种官方氏族格子呢的概念是伟大高地复兴运动的一部分。天哪，氏族格子呢大约始于1810年。好吧，是的，200年是很久远了，但与氏族本身的年龄相比，这根本算不了什么。麦克达夫（The Macduff）、麦克道格（The Macdougles）、麦克奎里（The Macquaries）、麦克卡伦（The Macallons），这些的历史接近一千年。但基本上，在19世纪，许多氏族领袖只是去挑选了他们喜欢的格子呢，
and renamed them after themselves. Is this kind of like what's your favorite? Yeah, absolutely. Yep, you know, the Campbell chief used the Black Quarched Arten. The Chief of the McKenzie used the 78th or Seaforth Arten. The first and sealed as his true clan tartan, a tartan that's 10 years earlier been being sold as Caledonia. Tartan, plaid, whatever you want to call it. The pattern has taken on so many different meanings and associations. And it has been used symbol has taken on so many different meanings and associations, and it has been used symbolically to unite so many different groups of people. On the surface, the pattern
并以他们自己的名字重新命名。这有点像问你最喜欢什么？是的，绝对是。是的，你知道的，坎贝尔（Campbell）族长使用的是“黑watch”格子呢。麦肯齐（McKenzie）族长使用的是“第78或西福思”格子呢。他第一个将其确认为他的真正氏族格子呢，一款在十年前就被当作“喀里多尼亚”（Caledonia）格子呢出售的格子呢。Tartan格子呢、plaid格子呢，随便你怎么叫它。这个图案已经承载了如此之多的不同含义和联系。它已被象征性地用来团结如此之多的不同群体的人。表面上看，这个图案
seems simple, right? It's just a series of overlapping threads, a warp and a weft. But really, if you look at it and get your nose right up close and notice the number of colors, the stripe width, the variation in the ways the threads overlap. You can see it's quite complex, and it can be particular enough to be specific and general enough to be for everyone. I mean, just, yeah, like cultural, just visibility, being able to walk down the street and be like, oh that's another person who's like me, I feel was alone. Like that can be something that Plaid does, which is kind of amazing if you think about a fabric, I'm having power culturally.
似乎很简单，对吧？它只是一系列交织的纱线，有经线和纬线。但事实上，如果你仔细观察它，把鼻子凑得很近，注意到颜色的数量、条纹的宽度、纱线交织方式的变化，你会发现它是相当复杂的，它可以具体到足以具备独特性，也可以普遍到足以属于每个人。我是说，只要，是的，比如文化上的，仅仅是可见度，能够走在街上然后觉得，哦，那是另一个像我一样的人，我觉得不再孤单。就像那是格子呢能够做到的一件事，如果你考虑到一块布料竟然在文化上拥有这种力量，这其实挺神奇的。
The pocket, the piece of paper Words from yesterday There's a portrait painted on the things we love. Articles of Interest is made by myself, Avery Trouffleman, edited by Joe Rosenberg, bagpiping by David Watson, other music by Ray Royal, and intro and outro themes by Sassami Ashworth. Fact check by Graham Haysha, mixed by Kelly Coin,
口袋，那张纸，昨日的话语，在我们所爱之物上绘有一幅肖像。《感兴趣的物件》由我本人——艾瑞莉·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）制作，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）剪辑，大卫·沃森（David Watson）吹风笛，其他音乐由雷·罗亚尔（Ray Royal）提供，片头和片尾主题曲由萨萨米·阿什沃思（Sassami Ashworth）创作。事实核查由格雷姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）完成，混音由凯利·科恩（Kelly Coin）负责，
and Roman Mars is the macho highlander of this whole series. A very special thanks to Crystal Beniz, Isabelle Sloan, Rachel White, Pyrogaultmann, Christina Stokes and Ian Ferguson, as well as Katie Mingle, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sharif Yusef, Vivian Lee, Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead, and the whole 99Pi team. There's a portrait of painting the things below. Scots are really adamant that kilt are not skirts. Okay, but there's this one important way that kilt are very similar to women's wear. What are you wearing right now?
罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）是整个系列中的硬汉高地人。特别感谢水晶·贝尼斯（Crystal Beniz）、伊莎贝尔·斯隆（Isabelle Sloan）、蕾切尔·怀特（Rachel White）、派罗·高特曼（Pyrogaultmann）、克里斯蒂娜·斯托克斯（Christina Stokes）和伊恩·弗格森（Ian Ferguson），以及凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Yusef）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）以及整个99Pi团队。在我们所热爱之物上绘有一幅肖像。苏格兰人坚决认为苏格兰短裙不是裙子。好吧，但苏格兰短裙与女装有一个非常重要的相似之处。你现在穿的是什么？
So I'm wearing my kilt, which is a McPherson ancient tartan. My kilt shoes, kilt brooks, and then to top it up, I've got a Jurassic Park t-shirt. This is David McPherson, who I met outside of bar in Edinburgh. And when he wears his kilt, he also has to wear something called a sporen. So what's a sporen? A sporen is a big furry purse. It's a fur and leather purse that sits right over the crotch.
我身上穿的是苏格兰短裙，这是麦克弗森（McPherson）古代格子呢款。我的短裙鞋、短裙袜，然后最上面，我还穿了一件《侏罗纪公园》T恤。这是大卫·麦克弗森（David McPherson），我在爱丁堡一家酒吧外面遇到了他。当他穿苏格兰短裙时，他还得穿一种叫做“毛皮腰包”（sporen）的东西。所以什么是sporen？Sporen是一个巨大的毛茸茸的包。这是一个挂在胯部正前方的皮毛小包。
And it kind of hangs on a chain, round your hips. That attaches to your belt. That attaches to your belt. Because kilts don't have any pockets. So you need to keep your stuff somewhere. So right now I've got my phone in it. I've got my keys. I've got my wallet. Other people, I don't know, they might keep Braveheart on DVD or...
它差不多是用一条链子挂在你的臀部周围。系在你的皮带上。系在你的皮带上。因为苏格兰短裙没有任何口袋。所以你需要把你的东西放在某个地方。所以现在我的手机在里面。我的钥匙在里面。我的钱包在里面。其他人，我不知道，他们可能会在里面放《勇敢的心》DVD或者……
I would prefer pockets. I mean, it's not. You can't get very much in it. Your next article of interest is pockets. Radio Topeon. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我更想要口袋。我的意思是，这不太行。你塞不了太多东西进去。你的下一个感兴趣的物件是：口袋。来自PRX的Radio Topia。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。